[Music]
faces are the most
important subject matter in art
it's a never-ending source of material
when you put on one of my masks you
become somebody different
you start to embody that character and
have a lot of fun with
it my name's landon meyer
and i make disturbingly realistic masks
[Music]
i never thought i was going to make a
living doing masks i was a picture
framer loan officer pizza delivery
driver and then i got laid off
i've always been interested in doing
something that's like really surreal and
nightmarish
so it was more or less an experiment
that took off
i am the only person out there that's
doing hyper realistic likeness masks
i'm kind of this weird mad scientist
down in the basement
[Music]
i start off getting lots of reference
material
the hardest part is doing the sculpture
that can take anywhere from four days to
a year but once the sculpt is done and i
have a mold it's about a one week
process to make a mask
they are ungodly expensive they range
500 and up and sometimes even high is 7
500
over the years i've made approximately
25 different designs and i've produced
with my own hands over a thousand masks
what i make i like to consider wearable
art
these are
super realistic sculptures you can put
over your head and wear
people just seem to have this astonished
reaction to the masks that's what i love
about them
[Music]
you